let's start to unpack this question
together and work out what is going on
and why I've chosen to highlight this
particular question for you the question
begins in a pretty stock standard way
and there are no curveballs in the
question itself calculate the volume
apart from the poor grammar because I
had to rewrite the question halfway
through formed by this area here this is
the green one y equals e to the X plus
one x equals three and then you've got
your coordinate axes so you can clearly
see the green area and what's been
formed what is missing on my diagram is
my indication that I'm rotating that
around the x axis so that's what gives
you this kind of shape here right you
see that can you picture the potter's
wheel in your mind and it's spinning
around and there's your shape okay
so when you go to calculate the volume
of this we haven't done volumes
explicitly for a little while so it
might be worth just writing down without
any reference to this particular
question
it might be worth writing down just the
normal standard volume formula I'm
rotating around the x-axis so which
formula shall I use okay so I've got
some boundaries which I'm going to fill
in in a second I'm adding up cylinders
that's why it starts with a pie and then
because Russell don't take over I'm
going around the x-axis very good
fantastic so there's our pie R squared H
in this case all of our R Squared's are
going this way so it's right to Y and
all h's are going this way which is
right it's a d X so that ah there's the
formula okay now in this particular case
what have we got well I haven't told you
explicitly what both of the boundaries
are so you have to find one of them
what's the lower boundary it's just mr.
zero right I chained it and put on my
diagram but the question itself sort of
implies that when it says the coordinate
axes
what's my upper boundary they do tell
you this one I can't read the question
it's three that's how far I'm going to
go across so I was trying to consider
conserve space so I'm going from north
to three the pie is still there in this
case what is my function y
here it is right here right now don't
forget the whole thing is why so the
whole thing is being squared right so
let's write the whole piece in there and
I'm integrating with respect to X happy
tomes
so everyone seem ok so far we're
tracking a lot now at this point is
where I'm going to say this is why I've
highlighted this question we've seen
this at the HSC level before it happens
all the time and you've got an
exponential in here which are
traditionally very easy to integrate
functions so what could possibly go
wrong here when you look at this what's
your instinct for how to deal with this
integrate here what are you going to do
with it when you have something squared
it's very tempting to either think these
are both the same thing with different
names either integration by substitution
of some kind or or reverse chain rule
it's very tempting to think that right
there's a slight problem with that if I
wanted to do think back to yesterday if
I wanted to do a reverse chain rule on
this right here's your inside function
right so what would your inside
derivative be because that that has to
be somewhere in here what would it
that'd be in this case it would be e to
the X wouldn't it the plus one you
differentiate that it just disappears
just a constant so I need another EDX
flying around somewhere but as you can
see it's nowhere to be found right so
the reverse chain rule you can try it
but it doesn't get you anywhere and you
end up not being able to change your
variable you'll stuck with this DX you
can't change it into D U or whatever
okay so what else can I do if I can't
use reverse chain rule how else can I
deal with this power that's I'm
expanding is the other way to go right
now usually we would say this is simpler
than the expanded form and we always try
to avoid expanding because expanding
makes lots of terms rather than a few
terms but in this case because reverse
chain rule doesn't work you sort of left
without options so this is a good enough
time to put the pie at the front I've
dealt with it it's a constant I'm going
from nought to three okay now just be
careful what is this squared because
even once you know to square it people
into unit and extension once still mess
this up
is a plus B all squared where this is a
this is B so what's the expansion down
here it'll be it'll be a squared which
is this now just remember your index
laws right this will be e to the 2x very
good in the middle you've got the plus
to a B don't you so what's plus to a B
in this case to e to the X that is the
last bits B squared which in this case
mercifully is simple it's just a plus
one sound all right now a lot of people
miss this bit up because we're not used
to squaring these things we're used to
seeing like powers of X in here but
that's an exponential so your brain kind
of has to go in two directions at once
we respect to X that all right that was
all the hardest parts of this question
but we're not quite out of the woods
just yet so can help me integrate this I
have a pie I'm trying to think of the
primitive now I could separate this out
into multiple integrals but we're saying
it quite familiar with this we've done
like by this stage every single one of
you fingers crossed if you don't you
know way has done hundreds of integrals
so I'd like to be able to do this
without doing that weird pull it to
there put a half out the front to try
and comp and say I wonder if you can see
straight away what the integral of this
part will be this should be half e to
the 2x right just mentally check for
yourself you don't have to write this
down if I differentiate this will I
return back the answer is yes your chain
rule will cancel out that half so you
will end up with this thumbs up okay you
want to get to that point where one of
the reasons why we've run out of time is
because we don't have fluency to get to
and islets like this quickly and that
comes with practice how did this guy can
you find the primitive to a to the X
it's just to a to the X this is why we
like doing calculus with Exponential's
it's really simple last 1 plus 1 2
becomes plus X there we go and I've got
to batteries last potential curveball in
here it's easy to fall into the trap
that when 0 is your lower boundary which
it very very frequently is because you
get situations like this commonly it's
really tempting to think all the 0 just
evaluates out the only
thing that really matters is the top
boundary and then off you go which would
give you this of course a half a dove a
6 plus 3 cubed plus 3 okay that would be
the upper boundary but of course the
lower boundary doesn't just become 0
does it because when you put 0 in here
what does this first term become it'll
be 1/2 times 1 and then this is going to
become 2 times 1 so you've got sort of
important things there that you want to
write down so I'm going to subtract my
lower boundary you just said what you're
saying 1/2 plus 2 and then there's a
plus 0 hang you idiot are you okay there
I've seen a lot of you come to me and
say I've got a problem my art is really
closed but like I've got all of this
right and where it's gone wrong as we
just assume that the lower boundary 0
happens all the time
once you're conscious of it you'll do it
less can you help me simplify this just
to finish it off pies still out the
front what's left ok this guy is nothing
to collect terms with this guy is
nothing to collect terms with 3 take
away 2 and a half so I think we end up
with that there are two things to just
round this all off
number one what was the question again
the question was volume right so I
should say what units is this these are
in in a second and the other thing is
just as a minor note I could write this
simpler I don't like so many fractions
be there there's nothing wrong with this
do you Merkley but I am going to take
out a factor of two like so which leaves
me with this how many cubes will I have
because I took out a fact over half
think I'll have four of them right
everything's getting doubled on the
inside that's that and of course the
units that we referred to you okay with
that so a few traps for young players
when you look at it in summary there's
nothing dramatically hard about this oh
it is a bit long right but there are
lots of teeny little things where it's
like where did I make an error on this
there are really small things that can
come up and they're the kinds of times
when you sort of facepalm yourself after
an exam because you know how to do this
you just made a routine error okay